un peu de matière sèche
fédérer autour de la réduction des
déchets une priorité pour Didier Chambon
c'est une montant de 53 ans a monté en
2017 se compose collectif dans sa
copropriété il a suivi cette année une
formation pour devenir guide composteur
l'objectif accompagner les familles dans
une bonne gestion des biodéchets tout
est parti d'un petit groupe de voisins
qui partageaient les un petit peu les
mêmes valeurs environnementales comme
ici on a une copro ça doit passer par un
vote en assemblée générale et donc nous
à notre grande surprise ça a été voté à
l'unanimité on faisait des tri déjà
mais on à la fin les déchets qui étaient
pas recyclables étaient mélangées avec
les déchets qui pouvaient justement
faire partie de compost pendant notre
famille c'était intéressant pour ça de
montrer les enfants que la nature elle
est elle est cyclique sur les 110
familles de la résidence une quarantaine
participent au compost ce procédé permet
d'éviter environ 85 kg de déchets par
habitant et par an un véritable intérêt
écologique mais aussi un vecteur de lien
social
ça nous a permis de rencontrer des gens
un petit peu introverti des gens qui se
sont proches de la nature et besoin de
pouvoir participer à ce genre de projet
et avec qui on a mis des amitiés le
petit monde vient le dimanche le samedi
le dimanche en fonction de quand on
organise le retournement on met cette
outil c'est pas la braise compost on
tourne c'est une hélice ça rentre tout
seul donc on le rentre sur une vingtaine
centimètres on ressort donc la matière
qui était en dessous passe au dessus
et ça permet d'aérer le compostage c'est
un procédé on va dire de dégradation de
des biodéchets donc les épluchures les
peaux de bananes marc de café à partir
de 6 mois on obtient du compost donc le
compost c'est un petit peu ce qu'on voit
au pied des armes dans la forêt c'est
l'humus en fait le fruit du travail
collectif est ensuite redistribué aux
habitants et utiliser pour le potager de
la résidence cet engrais naturel servira
à enrichir les plantations en mars 2023
Didier Chambon passera une formation
professionnalisante pour devenir maître
composteur il sera notamment habilité à
gérer des projets de compostage auprès
des collectivités